I want to congratulate you you got an
Emmy nomination for the comeback you
came back for two seasons nine years
after the first I think it's kind of
unprecedented in the history of
television yeah did the first season and
then you waited nine years and you came
back and the show as great as the first
season was I thought it was even better
oh yeah when you came back and everyone
else agreed and you got an Emmy
nomination critics went insane yeah what
a challenge to revisit that character
nine years later well yes I mean a huge
challenge it was terrifying yeah you
know because people who like the show
knew we had seen it a lot so we did
whenever him to disappoint yeah well
basically what that endeavor was well
you did not but I know that there was a
lot I know you felt a lot of pressure I
remember calling you up and telling you
that I was I was somewhere I think was
doing something for the MTV Music Awards
or something or video I forget but I was
on a lot somewhere and I heard a grown
adult screaming and jumping up and down
with joy and I didn't know what had
happened and it had just been announced
that the comeback that you're gonna make
more episodes yeah I I thought I've
never heard that kind of excitement in
my life yeah well that a show was coming
back it was trying to get your email
yeah cuz we don't actually know you know
I don't know right but we got your email
I was like Michael look at right people
are Conan says people are excited out
there about real world that's because
Lisa I go outside you're inside Conan
says it's going over Cracker Jack
oh you're adventurous you go outside I
go outside on to other Lots you play
Valerie cherish and your middle name is
Valerie was was that like you giving
like a nod to the fact that that was
your middle name is that is that
something that a name you liked when you
were growing up yes Lea
yes I mean I'm kind of making fun of
myself in that and fair with me but when
I was in junior high school I thought
Lisa was too common and silly a name
like there's no Lisa oh you take
seriously in the world but Valerie the
name of substance right and I tried to
change my name to L Valerie Kudrow and
my parents wrote you know whatever I
wanted to do they were always like look
alright and because they're very they
were always very laid-back yeah if you
want to do something you can do it yeah
yeah yeah all right
all right and I tried to get all my
friends to call me L Valerie its L
Valerie now it's L Valerie and then I
just lost all my friends and so there
was no one to call me Valerie no one
would do it right and so I just when we
were coming with the character I was
like oh she's the type that would think
Valerie is a sophisticated name but
still kind of fun and you know like with
the red hair yeah for comedy cuz it's
not dumb blonde and it's not sexy
brunette but it's someone you take
seriously well I've not had that
experience this event had let's take him
seriously what planet are you living on
I also tried to get glasses cuz I
thought now that's gonna be fun wait you
wanted to wear glasses yes yes did you
get glasses when you were no but I found
a doctor who's like I mean they're a
little off you could get glasses and my
told my parents I need glasses they said
alright
your parents were okay with everything
everything I made a grace - that'll be
different